all right so while the media politicizes
yet another tragedy president Trump is
once again he's leading the way on this
recovery effort along with the governor
and lieutenant governor of Texas and
local officials and offering his full
support here's what the president said
earlier today in Springfield Missouri
the citizens of Texas and the Gulf Coast
need all the prayers support and
resources our communities have to offer
recovery will be tough but I have seen
the resilience of the American spirit
firsthand all over this country to the
people of Houston and across Texas and
Louisiana we are here with you today we
are with you tomorrow and we will be
with you every single day after to
restore recover and rebuild
now unfortunately the destroyed Trump
media they won't focus on how hard the
president and good politicians in Texas
are working for all these flood victims
instead the abusively bias press they're
stealing a page from the Democrats
playbook and just like Chicago Mayor
Rahm Rhambo dead fish Emanuel once
infamously said never let a crisis go to
waste talking about politics right now
millions of Americans are facing carnage
and heartbreak caused by what may end up
being the most expensive natural
disaster in the history of this country
the media seemingly they don't care at
all they're using this as an opportunity
to go after the president now yesterday
the president he traveled to Texas he
wanted to survey the damage and offer
his full support but of course that's
not good enough for the elite left-wing
media because by the way it never is if
he cured cancer it wouldn't be enough
they still found a way to twist and
distort what the president's trip was
about for example the partisan press
they tried to create a fake news
controversy over the first lady's shoes
when she went aboard marine one how
small how petulant how petty how
insignificant is the left in the media
in this country when that's all they
care about and they're failing miserably
in exposing themselves then they took
things a step further they tried to say
that President Trump has no empathy for
the victims now take a look at their new
line of attack we're highlighting all of
the examples with our favorite ding
sound again alright watch this today
President Trump visited Texas but he
forgot to bring any empathy with him so
the president used today's hurricane
coverage to promote Trump merchandize it
was very striking that he didn't mention
the number of people who have died or
even you know sort of try to empathize
with the fact that people are genuinely
sufferings it seems to me it's just
concerned about optics just concerned
about optics and I want to because I
wish they would be concerned about
people I don't think that he understands
the human scale of misery I don't think
that he could connect with the sort of
compassion that you normally have when
you see a disaster like that he's always
calling attention to himself
I coulda done far more empathy for the
people I would hope he had some empathy
he has trouble talking about things
besides himself very little in terms of
empathy from this president very little
in terms of emotion or talking directly
to the people of Texas this is way
beyond petty this would beyond
disgusting beyond shameful even for the
destroyed Trump media the president has
no empathy for suffering Americans
really now they clearly were not paying
attention to his campaign remember that
was based on helping Americans get out
of poverty off of food stamps in other
words the Forgotten men and women in
this country that need jobs and as we've
been showing you night in and night out
this is what the media does they always
find a way even during a tragedy to go
after the president try and discredit
the president D legitimize him the first
lady his family his advisers anybody
that likes him and is associated with
him it just never fails and it's why the
president took to Twitter this morning
to fight back and to put out his truth
which is obviously what people need to
see and he wrote after witnessing
firsthand the horror the devastation
caused by Hurricane Harvey my heart goes
out even more to the great people of
Texas then he wrote after reading the
false reporting and even ferocious anger
in some dying magazines it does make me
wonder why all I want to do is make
America great again
and then later added texas-louisiana we
are with you today we are with you
tomorrow and we will be with you every
single day after to restore recover and
rebuild so this week the line of attack
is oh the president's heartless he
doesn't care about the victims and oh
let's pay attention to the shoes that
his wife is wearing the first lady and
last week it was the president is unfit
and unhinged it never ends
you see this media shameless agenda it
just continues to be exposed I say it's
going to all boomerang back against them
they wanted from day one to damage
destroy the president with every chance
they get and if they can't find one
they'll make up a reason regardless of
what he does and guess what it's you the
American people it's you the American
people that will remain suffering and
guess what it's not the out-of-touch
overpaid lazy left-wing ideologues that
are my so-called colleagues I'm
embarrassed to be associated with them
in the media now remember there was so
wrong about the 2016 election they also
don't care about the President's agenda
we told you last week about all of the
items of success they never reported on
them all the proposals that will help
millions Americans that are suffering
after eight years of failed Obama
policies that they never reported on for
example will the media cover fairly the
president's tax reform pitch that he put
out today and here's the president from
earlier explaining why America
desperately needs to have tax cuts and
overhaul the tax system I am fully
committed to working with Congress to
get this job done and I don't want to be
disappointed by Congress do you
understand me first we need a tax code
that is simple fair and easy to
understand
second we need a competitive tax code
that creates more jobs and higher wages
for Americans it's time to give American
workers the pay raise that they've been
looking for for many many years
the third principle for tax reform is a
crucial one tax relief for middle class
Emily's fourth and finally we want to
bring back trillions of dollars in
wealth that's parked overseas millions
of struggling citizens will be lifted
from welfare to work they will love
getting up in the morning they will love
going to their job they will love
earning a big fat beautiful paycheck
they will be proud again I am asking
everyone in this room and across the
nation to join me in demanding nothing
but the best for our nation and for our
people
and if we do these things and if we care
for and support each other and love each
other then we will truly make America
great again now the president just like
he's been doing for months he's leading
he's offering solutions do you ever hear
any of these ideas from the media do
they want to do the same thing have they
ever offered up ways to solve the
problems of those Americans that are in
trouble and suffering or ways to make
people's lives better
no they're obsessed with tearing down a
president Russia Russia Russia Russia
Russia you know examining the
president's mental state well what about
their trumped arrangement syndrome you
know what it's time now for Congress to
get on board get behind this tax plan
that will create jobs pass legislation
look at this brand-new Fox poll out
tonight on the issue of passing tax
reform this year 49 percent of
registered voters said yes it's
important 78 percent said it's unlikely
to happen well that means it's time for
congressmen to get to work and where do
we show you the polls about Congress and
Paul Ryan and Mitch McConnell tonight
they need to pay attention and compare
their poll numbers to the president
because the American people need things
done it's good for the country it's good
for those people that have been left
behind and if Congress can pass tax
reform like Ronald Reagan did it will
unleash a new wave of American
prosperity and millions of new jobs and
get millions of Americans off food
stamps and out of poverty and back in
the labor force and a shot at the
American dream so it's time to put the
country first Congress get busy